on évacue la piscine il y a un varan
énorme à la réception tout le monde est
flippé ah vous voyez ou pas la queue le
long et tout la tête mais c'est comme
accommodo en Indonésie
ils vont le mettre dehors
mon dieu mais attendez on se met où mais
ça si ça te porte à de tout qui gangrène
c'est très dangereux oui tu meurs
quelle sensation là je sens l'air qui
passe c'est flagrant
mais le mulet il est là mais on a quand
même il est toujours là
on est d'accord que l'humilier pour
l'instant c'est bien
et après du coup étape on coupe chou
je vais vous annoncer quelque chose qui
est pour moi un
immense plaisir j'espère qu'il sera
partagé par vous tous
à savoir que
mon président a décidé de me prolonger
jusqu'en 2026
[Musique]
je passe sortie avec des mecs hyper
beaux hein clairement je l'assume
plusieurs fois quand j'ai ramené des
déchets les gens me disaient ah mais
c'est pas parce que Miss France d'argent
à côté
[Musique]
dans ma vie avant d'être miss France
ouais bien sûr comment il s'appelle déjà
quand je les vois aujourd'hui je me dis
c'est pas plus qu'un 4 5 sur 10
mon cœur mon cœur
j'ai rêvé que pour ma dernière date de
tournée
jouer à Bercy non non
j'ai joué et c'était la folie tu
m'entends